the drive to Whittier is gorgeous and
fascinating you go past Lake Portage and
portage glacier and through some of the
most beautiful mountains and waterfalls
it's an absolutely breathtaking location
but the Whittier tunnel is fascinating
the Whittier tunnel is a two and a half
mile single lane tunnel so you have to
wait your turn to drive through the
tunnel all traffic going to Whittier
leaves on top of the hour and traffic
from Whittier leaves on the 30 the train
traffic Oso has its own schedule as well
so when you arrive you sit in this
beautiful valley and wait your turn to
enter the tunnel
the Whittier tunnel is the second
longest tunnel in North America it's
fascinating as you can see it's just one
lane so and there's the railroad tracks
you're actually driving on top of the
railroad tracks other than the little
emergency exit sidewalk on the left side
that's it and you're just driving for
about eight to ten minutes through a
mountain and it's it's a it's an
experience because this tunnel is so
long
a fixation and fire is like a really big
hazard so they've got this emergency
escape route on the sidewalk on the side
and they also have these emergency like
safe houses every several hundred yards
so if there's a fire you can hide this
bunker and until help arrived and
because two cars can't fit in the tunnel
they have motorcycles that are strong
enough to pull a fire engine
they used a tow wrecks out of the tunnel
the city of Whittier is also a very
fascinating place
Whittier gets about 20 to 40 feet of
snow in the wintertime so it's a
difficult place to build a home in a
difficult place to live so everyone in
the town lives in that apartment
building on the hill this is really
really small town with hardly any
buildings but it's absolutely gorgeous
which is a great place to catch some
fish to go on a charter maybe just do a
little day trip sightseeing wherever you
do make sure you get back in the tunnel
in time because it closes that night but
we had a great trip
meet Tommy and my father going out to
Whittier and back and we had a great
time fishing it and caught a lot of fish